So I'm here with Jessica Uelmen
who's the program manager for
the mobile Nanodegrees here at Udacity.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Happy to be here.
>> [LAUGH] So
first thing I wanted to ask about,
was this is an ed-tech class and
many of our students might be looking
at developing educational technology for
mobile devices.
So what are some of the unique
opportunities that take place on
mobile that we don't necessarily
have on more traditional computers.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think number one, your
phone is always glued to you, right?
I mean, when is there an opportunity
when you don't have your phone on you?
So that also opens the opportunity
to learn at any time.
So for example, if you're on the train,
if you're in a ridiculously long queue,
just anywhere that you have time,
you can start learning.
So I think then thinking
of a learning experience
to help students learn when
they just have the time.
At any time instead of at home
on the couch making time for it.
>> Mm-hm, so it sounds like
mobile technology is great for
developing some education applications.
I'm guessing it's not a matter of
if you build it, they will come and
there are some things we
can do wrong with it.
So what are some of
the unique challenges or
obstacles to doing good mobile
technology for education?
>> Yeah, I think, when I think of it,
I think there's two real
ones that stick in my mind.
For one,
there's programming challenges, right.
I mean, how do you do complex
programming challenges on a phone?
And on most mobile devices
like the iPhone in particular,
you can't compile anything.
It's against Apple's terms of service.
So how do you teach
programming in that regard?
And then also how do you make it not so
gamey, right?
I mean, how do you make people feel
like you're not just progressing through
a level and it's like Math Blaster or
something, right?
I mean, how do you make it
a substantial learning experience.
I think one company that does
that very well is Duolingo.
I think that then learning a language,
it's great, I can fit small chunks in.
At any time, learn words, come back and
revisit things and
it doesn't feel gamey.
It feels like I'm actually learning and
making progress each time.
>> I imagine language is a particular
one where being able to learn on the go
is very valuable.
Because it's something you use
everyday throughout your life.
>> Right.
>> As opposed to programming,
you're not usually actually
doing programming on a train,
you're programming at home But
there are other skills we learn that
we would actually use in this context.
>> Absolutely.
>> So are there any new trends or
new emerging parts of mobile technology
that are emerging that will be
useful in developing future
educational technology?
>> So actually, I think one of
the most exciting things is the watch.
I mean, so I have an Android watch and
it's really surprised me
at how useful it's been.
If for nothing else, just reminders.
Hey, you've got a meeting,
or hey, you need to do this.
So if for anything else,
helping students set those learning
habits to really make time for
education.
Could be a really,
really great application moving forward.
>> Yeah, it's very true.
I hadn't really thought about that, but
that could be very useful for things,
like a guided tour of a museum or
something like that.
It seems almost a silly little
difference to have the device be on your
wrist or in your pocket.
Either way, they're always on you.
But just that hands-free and
always visible nature of it
can really change things.
>> No, absolutely.
May be there's even bite-size
learning segments that you can get,
where all of a sudden,
oh, your wrist vibrates.
Here's a quick question or
learning snippet that you can quickly
look at, answer and then move on.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
And by the same token, so when we
think about these mobile devices for
education, I think we often think about
the fact that they have a screen that
can show us information.
They're web-enabled,
it's pretty much it.
But they have a lot of other things
like cameras and GPS and microphones and
things like that.
Can those also be used for
education some ways?
>> Yeah, absolutely in certain ways.
So one of the examples that
I first think about is
I'm really interested in hardware.
I come from an Electrical Engineering
background and learning experiences for
hardware becomes inherently
a lot more challenging.
So devices like the camera for example,
if you're building a printed circuit
board or building a circuit and
maybe it's not working properly.
And you don't know what's going wrong.
It's not like you can send an email to
your professor and say, here's a digital
version of my printed circuit board or
my circuit, what's going wrong?
Maybe taking a picture or video and
then being able to easily send it.
Provides a lot more opportunity for
faster feedback and
then even assessment
at the end of the day.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
So we might have students in this class
who are looking at developing their
project, their class project
using a mobile device.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Do you have any suggestions,
just as we sign off for
them if they're looking to do that?
>> I think in a lot of ways,
keep it simple.
I think that comes up a lot.
People get entranced by
the phone as a medium and
tend to want to throw a lot of features
and a lot of different things into it.
So really get to basics and
try not to let feature creep come in so
much, so that it becomes this giant
app that no one can navigate.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think that's a big thing and
then also just avoid gamification.
If you can.
It's just such an easy thing to slip
into and
such an easy thing to not do, right?
So to try to avoid
that whenever possible.
>> [LAUGH] And now you see why I
wanted to talk to Jessica as well.
Because as you probably know by now,
I am not a particularly big
fan of gamification either.
Thank you so much for talking to us.
>> Yeah, my pleasure.
>> [LAUGH]